in the last video we talked about the
short-lived and highly unsuccessful
english colony at roanoke island
which
disappeared pretty much without a trace
and even today is still known as the
lost colony so as late as 1585
england has still not successfully
established a new world colony well all
of that is about to change in 1607
when the virginia company
a joint stock company
or an early precursor to the modern
corporation which spread out both the
shares the wealth and the risk
of an expedition like one headed to the
new world they received a charter for
new world exploration from king james
the first
who had now taken over for queen
elizabeth
and their goals were kind of the same as
many of the goals of explorers in this
time period
they wanted to find gold
they wanted to find a passage
to
the
indies
that might make it easier for them to
get the luxurious materials like spices
and silk that were so expensive to get
over the land route that was the silk
road and james in particular was hoping
that they could maybe get one up on the
spanish
who had been doing so well for more than
a hundred years
in the west indies now one of the
important things to note about this
is that
no one who went to virginia expected to
set up a colony there and live there for
the rest of their lives what they
expected was to go for a couple of years
mine tremendous amounts of gold which
they hoped were you know lying in giant
piles all over the ground uh get
tremendously wealthy uh and live like
kings for the rest of their lives in
europe so this virginia company
expedition was intended to be short-term
but as it'll turn out that will not be
the case so how did things go for the
virginia company compared to the roanoke
island colonists well you know not
terrifically better they sailed in early
into the chesapeake bay and they spent
some time looking for what might be a
good place to settle and they eventually
chose a site
here on what they'll name the james
river for king james
and in the town that they'll call
jamestown for the same reason
it's hard to overstate how terrible
the land that they chose at jamestown
was
and it was terrible for a couple of
reasons uh one reason
is that the soil isn't terrifically good
there
it's
marshy
it's not great for growing subsistence
crops which you'll need to survive and
more importantly
it's buggy
by buggy i mean that there are tons of
mosquitoes
and mosquitoes carry diseases
like say yellow fever
malaria
and those
mosquito-borne diseases will have a
tremendous effect a huge death toll for
the early settlers at jamestown the
other thing i can't overstate about the
colonists at jamestown was just how
incredibly unprepared
and unsuited
they were to be
colonists in the new world
remember this was essentially a get rich
quick scheme well who are the sort of
people who'd like to get rich quick
investors for the most part these were
gentlemen
and the english definition of a
gentleman is really someone who has
title someone who has status someone who
does not work with his hands and all
through that first summer when they
probably should have been planting crops
to try to survive through the winter
instead these gentlemen were busy
looking for gold
which means that when winter rolled
around
things got pretty dire at jamestown and
we'll talk about that in the next video